here's a question do you think that
people cared about politics as much
before and we were just like too
ignorant because we were like too young
at the time
or do you think people care more now
because of the prevalence of social
media and just so many people
verbalizing their opinions and their
power
i don't think it has to do with the
amount of people caring i think this
just has to do with how much
we are just exposed to it now
yeah so i i think one of the main things
here is that you have to bear in mind as
well that i think like
with the internet this is just giving
everyone the platform yeah yeah so like
before if you wanted to if you wanted to
get support as a politician you had to
go on like a tv show and then say
something right yeah you only had light
water or if you're in japan you blare
out of a [ __ ] megaphone in the stream
annoyingly so like now it's like okay so
you have like the kind of perfect storm
of like
now there's more ways to to discuss
everyone's on the internet not even 40
50 year olds on the internet so they're
willing to listen to you yeah
combine that with the fact that it's
become really easy to give
politics a kind of tribalism with
nothing to do with it right so the whole
vaccination thing or whatever and all
that nonsense
non-vaccines nonsense but the whole
argument around it yeah yeah it very
quickly stopped becoming about the
science and more just about like which
horse are you backing yeah right so i
feel like now it became political it's
gotten really easy to just assign
identities to certain political views
yeah and this is how politicians have
realized that they can push their agenda
it's by just giving it like are you a
real american then you believe in this
right it's like how about you if you
push it used to be before i felt like it
was just about more so
it was like this is the policy this is
what we're gonna do and now it's like
all right we have to give everything a
meaning are you you're either with us or
you're not here's the meaning between it
and all that kind of [ __ ] i could
explain this better if i was more
eloquent with my words but unfortunately
that isn't the case i mean i mean they
did that subtly with the whole ebola
crisis right that was the exact same
thing like it suddenly became like a are
you with us or are you not with us do
you care about these people then you
should be with me it's like but it's got
nothing to do with it in what case sorry
the ebola stuff like what what do you
mean well like it very quickly became
like especially in america became like a
political drive right for like the
campaigns and whatnot and it's just like
well oh was it yeah i don't remember
yeah it absolutely did and then when the
actual election finished
everyone stopped talking about it
because it's as if it had nothing to do
with the american elections yeah because
i think it's just it's much easier
instead of proving yourself right to
prove the other person wrong oh yeah by
proving the other person wrong you're in
a sense proving yourself right even
though that's not how it works at all
you know like when did uh
when did like ben shapiro start owning
people with facts and logics right
because i feel like that's when it
started you know around the same time i
believe yeah yeah yeah yeah probably
when it was when it wasn't about
being involved in politics it was just
like you know you start off watching
someone else just like owning other
people in their like logistical like
logical arguments whatever you know it
became part of entertainment it was like
the what's this guy that proved me wrong
guy oh um um stephen crowder steven
crowder yeah i like that as well just
like [ __ ] exploded out of nowhere too
yeah it's weird how seeing the seeing
these waves come up first it's just like
you know you you have the group that
proves the other group wrong and then
and then after a while people get bored
of that and then it's like people
proving that group wrong and it's just
it's just like it's it's a constant you
know it's it's a constant ping-pong
[ __ ]
yeah
you know there's it's information on a
lot of things there's always way more
nuance than people want to to get into
right so a lot of the time if you just
take one correct argument or one correct
fact about a flawed argument right you
can just run with that and push that and
say like look this is this is right even
though in in context it might be
incorrect but you can just keep running
with something that that you know that
you you can parrot and it's safe to do
so yeah and even then even if you're
wrong it doesn't matter because as we've
learned is that if you're a narcissist
and you're willing to not give a [ __ ] if
people are trying to cancel you yeah
people have people have learned that
canceling only does [ __ ] if if you give
a [ __ ] yeah and and
people are being rewarded in mess uh you
know and a lot of those people like that
who uh
even though they get [ __ ] wrong as long
as they don't give a [ __ ] and they just
make something new or or don't mention
it and just continue on it doesn't
matter you get what you want you get
your platform you continue you can get
new followers oh you lost you lost a few
hundred followers oh you'll gain a new
thousand who cares yeah yeah exactly
it's like negative it's there's never
been more of a time when i've realized
that you know bad was it like bad press
or bad like there was no such thing as
bad yeah
i pressed yeah yeah yeah cause
it's as bad as you you give a [ __ ] and
yeah the thing is as well as a lot of
people have realized and a lot of you
see this on youtube's own influences
it's as bad as you let it seem it is as
well so if you're like you know that's
that's why a lot of the scandals around
the presidential election that happened
in 2016.
a lot of them because
if the guy who you're supporting is like
it's not a big deal yeah then maybe
you'll be like oh it's not it's not a
big team yeah i guess not yeah yeah you
know like there's kind of there is a
kind of uh it's as bad as they let it
seem right if you address it be like i
don't give a [ __ ] or you don't even
bother to address it then you know
yeah i mean yeah i mean i think
i think you're right in a sense and i i
feel like even more so was when it was
like when trump got elected like you
know regardless of your opinion you know
of him as a president for me as an
outsider who is you know not any part of
american politics it was almost like
watching a character in a show you know
like like see like going on your twitter
timeline and seeing some of the stuff
that he's like cartoon villain yeah yeah
yeah like remember like the whole cod
fifth [ __ ]
that shows like i don't care what where
you lie in the political spectrum i
think we can all unanimously agree that
call fifth was [ __ ] hilarious
and yeah it kind of like well i don't
know what the right word is but it kind
of like cartoonified [ __ ] yeah it kind
of like cartoonified your you know your
real life and you know the world events
even though
even though there is you know even
though these were real prevalent issues
and yeah he's had a real time
these had these had a real tangible
effect on the world and i feel like
especially a lot of the younger
generation who you know who have grown
up in the age of the internet um that's
that's kind of like the environment
they've grown into you know where where
everything when it's seen through a
phone or through you know through uh
through a tablet they just like it's
like suddenly not real yeah because
we're like we were like what 20 plus
when all this start happening i know
yeah 20 uh yeah maybe just nine i was
like 19. like i've i couldn't imagine
going from like 12 to like 18. yeah and
this has been your like entire yeah
memory yeah yeah
yeah
it's really bizarre yeah crazy and you
know we don't talk about it on the
podcast or political views or our
political opinions because i i the most
part i don't give a [ __ ] what you
believe in
yeah yeah
i have my own opinions but i'm also not
i i'm not like
i don't think i'm some kind of
benevolent man who knows
i know that i have come to conclusions
on things with through flawed like uh
thinking methodology whatever the [ __ ]
you say just because of how i've been
raised right and you've been raised
whatever way you have and if you
disagree with me on things i don't even
[ __ ] how you came about i'm not going to
judge you because i feel like one of the
biggest problems that's come out of all
this is that everyone's calling each
other stupid for believing in something
yeah and i'm like i'm sure you have a
reason if if we if we just spoke to each
other normally and didn't polarize each
other all the [ __ ] time yeah
just you know agree to disagree right
it's like we're not here to [ __ ] like
you know dangle a [ __ ] carrot in
front of your face being like believe us
because we we we hold the truth and it's
like no no one does it sucks as well
because obviously with the whole crown
of our stuff and that all got
politicized of course yeah of course it
did that unfortunately came at the cost
of people's lives yeah and you know the
people who felt they were right felt so
strongly they were right because they
thought that you know they're like yeah
we have to protect people and yeah
that's fair enough but it's it's kind of
difficult to convince people when you're
calling them stupid yes it's been shown
that it doesn't work no no no i mean i
think another big massive thing with the
age of the internet is just like the
[ __ ] overload of information yeah
right where where it's like i remember a
point where you you know read something
in a book or read a newspaper or
something and you know you'd you'd kind
of like educate yourself but it feels
like there is just so much information
right now that i don't even know what
information is the right information to
educate myself right so a lot of the
times yeah so many times i look at
something online and i think like oh man
this is
kind of interesting piece of information
a couple of hours later i found out it's
total [ __ ]
welcome it's like what the [ __ ]
welcome to real life
literally every time i'm just like
where sometimes you even you hear about
a story or an event and you're like [ __ ]
man that [ __ ] sucks yeah i get told
by like five or six different people
being like have you seen this thing and
i'm like well [ __ ] if there's five or
six people around me that i know yeah
and i understand yeah who's telling me
that this is happening then it must be
true and i'm like turns out not all
[ __ ]